so today I'm just gonna list some
lawsuits arising from this pandemic but
it's straight from the Washington Post
airlines have been sued over grounded
flights ticket brokers have been sued
over cancelled events insurers sued over
coverage limits grocers and internet
retailers sued over rising prices
hospitals sued over protective gear
University sued over closures amusement
parks sued over unusable season passes
ski resorts have been sued over refunds
strip club strip clubs have sued for
federal benefits a church has been sued
for holding services Cruise Lines sued
for sailing with the virus banks have
been sued for helping existing customers
first gyms sued for collecting
membership fees Walmart has been sued
for allegedly allowing a sick worker to
infect others target sued over the
efficacy of its hand sanitizer Hooters
has been sued over allegedly stinting on
severance I have no idea who she is
ride-hailing firms sued over sick leave
and multiple employers have been sued
for allegedly firing workers who
complained about safety measures so
here's a suggestion when the lockdown
lifts everyone goes back to work except
the lawyers seriously I think this is
the first time we are starting a
civilization with the burden of lawyers
when the world began you didn't need a
real-estate lawyer to buy a cave the
witch doctor didn't have to get
malpractice insurance there were no
recalls on the wheel and do you think we
even have fire if a lawyer was present
so to get us out of this hole today to
restart civilization we need lawyers to
lighten up
Congress should attach legal immunity to
these bailouts so companies and
organizations don't get ruined again you
know by some guy who yelled cough in a
crowded restaurant then when the economy
returns we can get back to suing the
crap out of each other this seems like a
plan that we could all get behind except
maybe the lawyers which means it's got
to be good
you know Dana I often you know I know
that we need lawyers it keeps things
civil so we don't go you know duel with
muskets but how can we expect businesses
and organizations to take the risks in
opening if somebody can pull like the
modern you know slip and fall saying
that they got sick at your Arby's yeah
and imagine that some of the rescue
money that was just passed by the
Congress has to go to actually pay for
lawsuits like this not to keep people on
the payroll which was the original
intent so I think this this goes back
maybe not to the caveman days but
whenever there is a crisis the trial
lawyers start chasing the ambulances
right this happens all the time and the
Republicans for years have been trying
to get tort reform passed in Congress
they have a strong strong support with
the Democratic Party but I think that
this is the time when you're going to
need compromise senator Mitch McConnell
this week has been talking about the
need for this and he said that the next
round of support money for the for
America will not pass if there is not
some sort of liability protection and
he's not saying that because he wants to
stick it to the lawyers necessarily he's
saying it because it is essential in
order to get the economy moving again if
companies are too afraid to start back
to work they're worried about getting
sued we're not going to be able to do
this properly now they have to figure
out a way to do it you know so that
companies still do what needs to be done
in order to protect workers and all of
us like whatever it's going to be in
terms of keeping things clean etc but
this legislation is going to pass but
and it's going to have liability reform
and I think this is finally time that
we're actually going to get a compromise
on this in Washington so what I'm not
talking about allowing restaurants or
any businesses to be incredibly careless
there's common sense but I feel like
there needs to be an ejection of
reasonableness of knowing that like it's
going to take some time to get our legs
back in this economy that's absolutely
right I agree 100% the only caveat I
throw in Greg is I think you can't
excuse camp companies who say to workers
come back to work but they've been
reckless or negligent in terms of
protecting those workers so that people
don't get hurt don't get sick
those companies should be held
accountable I don't think there's any
question about it but in terms of just
being reasonable
forget slip and fall we just have to be
reasonable with each other because we're
going through a difficult time yeah
exactly I think that there needs to be
like an office of reasonableness Jessie
which could be you could actually run it
and just say hey look lighten up
everybody I mean I kind of admire the
stripclub applying for federal benefits
yeah you know one's always talking about
all these people that are you know
getting applications through to apply
for these loans they're the ones
applying for the loans like the Lakers
applied for a small business loan and he
blames Trump how about you blame the
Lakers but here's a deal the Democratic
Party is in the pocket of the trial
lawyers every year the trial lawyers
donate what over a hundred million
dollars seventy-five percent of it goes
to Democrats they take their profits
from suing companies plow it back into
the Democrats coffers the Democrats get
reelected and they don't pass tort
reform that's the little shell game they
play but the Democratic Party economic
philosophy is not what we need right now
remember their philosophy is overburden
and over-regulate small business and
kind of downplay consumerism remember
you know you don't need this extra car
why are you getting a truck
don't take a vacation how much do you
really really need and then they're
making small businesses go out of
business they're suing them they're
accusing them of discrimination they're
making them compromise their religious
integrity that has to stop and now it's
going to be set up where the left is
hurting the recovery and Donald Trump is
going to be saying hey let's unleash
this thing and it's not a good position
to be in if you're a Democrat yeah
Kennedy I'm thinking about suing you for
no particular reason solid all right
I'll countersue you hey I like them
apples
it boils down to something that is very
unsexy but very much needed right now
and that
personal responsibility and that is a
two-way street and that means you can't
just go around blaming everyone else for
everything especially when you can't
prove your grievance so if if you're
immunocompromised and if you're older
don't go outside don't go back to work
and if you're an employer don't put your
employees in a situation where they
could become infected we all have to
help each other out and that doesn't
mean we run behind the courts as some
sort of a shield when our actions our
intellect and our rationality could have
helped us out in the first place
hmm excellent point